wir sind heute stiftsbibliothek
einsiedler klöster sind für lange zeit
die zentrale stelle wo bürger
überliefert und vor verlust geschützt
worden sind ist dass stefan material ist
mehr gewicht und er untersucht als
besonders wertvolle handschriften einmal
schön dass sie da sind wenn sie mir
zeigen was sie mit no hand ja er hat
zwei handschriften mit no es sieht zwei
us bürger vor witz unterschiedlich
konzipiert sie ähnliches gbagbo im
andere sind es wohl mehr so rebellieren
die texte enthauptet wo ihr mann artis
so button die zwei handschriften des
werkes cloud wo sie ihre beziehung
zueinander steuerung hier besteht im
moment wird die tägliche bibliothek sich
befindet sondern oder sie schon am
gleichen ort entstand nämlich in
konstanz im 80er jahre und essverhalten
zu so dass die eigene handschrift von
margarethe von kappel in auftrag gab
wurde nicht dass ich lieber hier und da
kann ich ja immer wieder sucht blätter
blüten und die abende die handschrift
ist eine wofür ihre tochter schwierig
vor technischen zwei tagen habe ich
selber geschrieben die ganze hand für
verbote wir sind wie lange sie kann
dafür aber leider nicht so genau wisse
sparbuch horstmann monat weiß er nicht
sie hat dafür investierte tagesschluss
frage sehr froh und sehr dass oder
andere tür genau und was geht nicht
durch konkret dass sie den auftrag an
sich ranlassen zwar nicht wie lange
sicht für die handschrift hinterlassen
wenn das sie damit fertig geworden ist
ich hoffe ich kurz vor lassen da wann
zahlt von der geburt und es ist herrin
jesu christi 1400 und in den 83 jahren
sang sie fest da kann ich durch die von
hof dort eher von hofer ist die frau
dieses buch muss geschrieben also 14
solche nachts gelassen auf unsere
jahreszahl ich hat sie das buch fertig
stellt und wenn konstant kleid genau
diese konstanz bürgers flog sie jeder
mal hätte die stadt wichtige amt
begleitet ich sah meine ganze auto
konstanz schlachthofs ist einfach süß
seines buchs muss man wohl sagen dass
mir das kann noch das eine jahr
rohstoffe also einerseits besteht
natürlich
allerdings muss dafür dass sauberer
strom ausgeschrieben und zu lassen das
ist nicht gegen die lästig das buch ist
wo ja ganz anspruchsvolle textsammlungen
taut und die dorothea von hof hat also
tatsächlich ganz beachtliche leistung
vollbracht sonne als intellektuelle
leistung diese kombination vor deine
handschrift
egal ob muss man natürlich habe das
quartett für die tatsächlich also für
die familie kovac wird im mittelalter
oder durch das ist einmalig ja also es
geht ihr text kombinationen gibt es
nochmals einziges mal mit einer
handschrift so wie überhaupt handschrift
der uniqa untergebracht würde sie
wirklich wichtig dafür gleichzeitig wird
er belieferte teil aus dem auto und so
den klar hätte jetzt mit uns natürlich
vor die türkischer handschriften wie
sich ist oder vor schaden bewahrt werden
also das volk sprachliche literatur
darunter zum zu die größte gruppe und
zwar mit großen abstand für mich dass
ich das erklären
also ich meine musiker frage führen dass
nicht alle
so bieten können italien könne lasse
gerade sieht ist es so breiten finden
also klar dass mario spiele nicht weiter
so in jede tapete jährige noch nicht
ganz so weit fortgeschritten ich sehe
das als statussymbol das kostet 3 mm
fahrzeuge das machen lassen und
geschrieben das ist auch wichtig sie ist
aber auch so dass man hat einfach
tatsächlich kein budget nach
schriftlichen vorlagen dass ich ja und
deshalb verständlich ich habe jetzt die
mister vorstellbar dass sie ganz häufig
steinen tauchte sie wo autoritäten
zurück schrieben sie also das gebiet vom
heilige augustinus erfolgen in der
andere heilige und mit einem taxi nach
dem hilfsversprechen verbunden
und hier wiederum funktioniert wenn er
tatsächlich genau dort blut vor dem
gebäude aber das finde ich erstaunlich
die bücher sind so alt eine extrem gute
halte was der zuschauer nicht wirklich
sie hat drei deshalb ist es logisch dass
die bücher sowie zwei kinder die an sich
nicht wirklich aber was hilft ist dass
konstanz klima herrscht uns dass man das
klima mit kunststoff für andere ist
wieso zu mithilft dass sie überall so
dass ich also meine gute zustand sie
also seine bibliothek wie es minister
hier sei jetzt eine barocke bewährte
x-bow r agiert hat eigentlich ganz gut
die voraussetzung dafür dass die
handschrift zu gelangen
es ist natürlich nicht dafür extra für
sich oder seine hufe quadro fx klima ist
hier ganz optimal einbringen team
natürlich immer wichtiger punkt mit der
eines klassischen ertrag die stadt
weiter und in die heutige zeit der
reformation tor gemacht hätte kohl
arisierung tor gemacht das hätte sie mit
dem kloster und für die schrift bedeutet
die meisten bücher war heute jetzt wie
sieht eine form vorliegt die echte
arbeit geschichte
eine fortgesetzte sie ihre handschrift
oder in konstanz entstanden sie und zwar
von frau waltraud klappt also nicht im
kloster und hört sich jetzt jeder der
bibliothek form einer kloster in
einsiedeln und dass der tag hat elvis
hits rekonstruieren
hier ist es so dass die nachricht sehr
schöne art von der familie klitschko
wollte sie und nachher gentechnisch in
das kloster wo sie zwischen konstanz und
danach hätte ich das irgendeine schuf
gelöst worden und ist nach roths 39 und
der stars oft lustlosigkeit bestand zwar
nach zürich aber diesmal weniger denn je
nach risiko und hatte wirklich
verantwortlichen als der damalige
stiftsbibliothek ein ganz wichtiger
bürgerversammlung vorsieht mit dem
einsatz verwundet
daher auf andere fahrer hätten für
buchbestand irgendwo der spitze der
umliegenden orten hätten sich bemüht die
handschriftlich hat seine sammlung das
konservieren gut geschichte von seiner
bibliothek unterstrich sehr langwierig
sprach sieht die schneider danke für das
gespräch
danke euch jetzt gerade empfangen die
kollegin barbara bleisch und yves bost
zum gespräch über diskriminierung
rassismus und vielfalt blieben dran